republicans blasting president biden for
pushing false statements about the new
georgia voting law
as democrats put more pressure on
corporations to fight back
the president's words which got four
pinocchios i would die if i ever got one
from the washington post now having real
world consequences after the mlb decided
to move their all-star game from atlanta
to protest the law
and georgia officials estimate that
decision to move the game will cost the
state 100 million dollars in tourism
revenue
here's georgia governor brian kemp on
that
people are getting screwed in this
martha it's a small
hard-working business people that are up
in cobb county and in the metro atlanta
area they're going to get hurt by the
all-star game being pulled from here
this is outrageous people need to stand
up and join the fight and say look we
are done
with the canceled culture in this
pressuring
and former new jersey governor chris
christie had this strong message for
biden
he's lying about this bill he's lying to
the american people about it
to cause the raging fire he said he was
going to put out he is lying
to cause racial divisions in this
country that's what he accused donald
trump is doing
and he's a liar and a hypocrite all
right
i also wanted to play some sound from a
restaurant owner in atlanta i could
imagine
how disappointed they are to not have
this business coming in
it's devastating it's devastating to the
city it's devastating to many businesses
mine included
it's uh it seems very um
unnecessary very punitive and
counter-intuitive intuitive to what
we're trying to do
uh by reopening lawrence last week you
were talking about
some of your thoughts about atlanta um
and how
and then right before the general
election last november you were telling
everybody that
the state is changing uh what do you
think now that now that mlb has decided
to leave
well yeah i kind of sounded alarmed
during election time because i was on
the ground and i was seeing the
demographic
shame the the ground game change
you know it's true that the republicans
are correct on the merits of this
um the washington post has already
destroyed the democratic party
on this when you've lost the washington
post then you know you're just straight
up lying
um most of the businesses that are over
here
virtual signaling they really don't care
about this issue they care about the
people
that are going to make them suffer from
a business standpoint
right they don't care about what's
happening in georgia
but none of that really matters winning
the argument
on the merits doesn't matter if you
don't win the people
and republicans often fall in this trap
i've been watching the governor of
georgia all day all week actually
talk about how he saw this coming from
the left that they
purchased the domain weeks ago then why
weren't you prepared for it
i watched the guy say well if they just
read the bill most of the legislators
don't even read the bill you think the
people are going to read the bill
so i've seen this circling from
republicans and it's
it is an often mistake that they make
you have to win the people now
republicans and conservatives like ben
shapiro would say
listen facts don't care about your
feelings that is true
based on the marriage but guess what
voters vote based on how they feel
and until republicans win the people on
the ground
they're going to continue to go through
this circling squad when it comes to
race republicans
always lose the battle when it comes to
race
because they don't win the battle of
ideas what do you mean by that
if republicans dominate on the ground
when it comes to school choice
if they dominate when it comes down to
gun issues
education the economy then they won't
have to worry about the race look at
ron desantis and florida he has won
people on school choice he's won black
voters latino voters because guess what
he won the battle of ideas when they try
to attack him on race
it doesn't work it's really interesting
uh perspective let me also have you all
listen
to jan saki of course he's the white
house press secretary about
whether president biden really wanted
mlb to
cancel out of atlanta watch
he was not dictating for what major
league baseball
should do that that they should
dictating they should move the all-star
game
that is was their decision they made
that decision and as he
stated earlier he certainly supports
that i'm not here to call for anyone on
behalf of the president or the vice
president or anyone
to take steps in reaction to the law in
georgia
katie it was almost like he was speaking
in his personal capacity
this is not the president speaking
yeah it was the president speaking and
the language was very carefully selected
after president joe biden went to
georgia
and had a meeting with stacey abrams who
was the one who has been pushing the
narrative that this is jim crow
2.0 and when it comes to all these
boycotts the democrats
own this stacey abrams is the one who
came up with this hyperbolic
language to describe this legislation
she's the one who's been leading the
charge
and lying about what's in the
legislation and joe biden
simply amplified it during that
interview on espn and jen saki when she
was asked about it multiple times at the
white house briefing
she also repeated the lies about what is
in this legislation now when it comes to
the argument that lawrence made about
republicans needing to win the people
on the issue of voter id 80 percent of
the country
nobody agrees on anything but 80 of the
country according to gallup
agrees that voter identification using
it to vote
is a valid requirement when it comes to
casting your ballot
and so republicans i think are not
backing down on this
that's a good thing they're standing up
and saying we're not doing this i love
that marco rubio called out the
commissioner
of the mlb saying well georgia is such a
racist
awful jim crow 2.0 state i assume you'll
be giving up your membership at augusta
where the masters are held because how
could you support that but of course
that would be
a personal thing that he would have to
give up the bottom line is as soon as
the mlb announced this the atlanta
braves cannot came out against it
counting commissioners and tourism
officials have come out against this
and all the small businesses are going
to suffer and the democrats
own this they drove the narrative this
was jim crow
and then there's a reaction to there
being jim crow laws back in place and
now they're all surprised
about their being a boycott this is on
democrats not republicans
charles barkley had this to say one if
you could put it up on the screen and i
will read it
to everyone it says i think most white
people and black people are great people
i really believe that in my heart but i
think our system is set up where our
politicians
whether they're republicans or democrats
are designed to make us not like each
other so they can keep their grasp of
money
and power they divide and conquer
any thoughts on that oh i love charles
barkley i think he's really
great but i must say i think if charles
barkley
was a major league baseball player right
now he might be one of those players who
wouldn't even go to an all-star game
in georgia given the current law i mean
you think about
delta coke uh other ceos
they're not you know just reacting to
nothing they're not stupid people
and they care deeply about their bottom
line but they're indicating here
that they don't want to be caught off
guard again they saw what happened
january 6th
in terms of the attack on the congress
they don't want to see
democracy undermined and along with it
the economic base of this country
they don't want to see that dana i think
they understand that's dangerous
what republican politicians are counting
on is that people
will not read the law that people will
allow them to get away
uh with what i think of as a just a
naked power grab that allows them to
strip
power from the secretary of state to
take power from local election boards
and to give all the power to count votes
and to certify elections to the
republican majority
in the state senate i mean
big lie the washington post or
republicans
no the washington post fact checker got
something that
joe biden said and called him out on it
properly lawrence but they didn't say
that they were with
uh the state of georgia and and governor
kennedy delta did i think what you said
everybody is saying hang on hang on just
a second please
what you have to understand is here
everybody is saying this is born of the
big lie that there was some tremendous
election fraud the election in 2020 was
stolen
let me just tell everybody listening
there's no argument here
it wasn't stolen it was a fair honest
election and this effort to change
election laws now
is just an effort by people who want to
be sure they win every future election
that's why you see
the response from corporate ceos greg
what do you
oh you can do that that nothing juan
said
is true you're saying that the corporate
you're saying that the corporations are
responding to january
6th no they're not in part no no no
now it's in part okay they are
responding to everything that happened
before that
meaning the billions in dollars
including an
arson that occurred over the summer
months in response to the
yes in response to the quote mostly
peaceful demonstrations okay
this is not a principle stand by
corporations
this is their way of saving their bottom
line
you even said it juan it's about the
bottom line
this is the corporation equivalent of
putting a blm
sign up on the front of your place of
business
so you hope that your windows don't get
busted
or your store get torched in these
mostly peaceful demonstrations
that's what they're doing this is we
know this is happening
the media has weaponized the accusation
of racism
on all potential behaviors and
corporations only want to make money
so they will do anything and i'll tell
you this if i were the woke right now
i would i would go for everything
because they have companies on the run
they should go to mlb and they should
say look a family of four costs 215
bucks
for them to go see a baseball game why
not make it more affordable
there should be two different tiers of
pricing for race
right let's have black families free
tickets do you know what mlb they will
probably go for it as a form of
corporate reparations because they are
terrified
now i do have a solution for this but it
makes too much sense we needed
operation warp speed for free ids
because i asked this before last week
and nobody had an answer even up to
today
do you know any people who don't have
ids do you know anybody besides illegal
aliens that don't have ids
and by the way if you do know somebody
that doesn't have an id do you might
think that they have bigger concerns
than actually getting an id for voting
so we know this is happening
this is purely a political grasp for
power
and what's happening is we never thought
as capitalists that it would be the
corporations that did us in
well they have there's no i hope biden
biden's talking about a 30 what a 27
percent in uh corporate
[Music]
70 80 you lost me
i'm no longer defending lower corporate
tax rates
i am now pure occupy wall street if they
can't stand up to the woke
then you lost the free market we no
longer care about you
you politicized you've turned
corporations
into enforcement arms of the of
political ideas
fostered by the media once that happens
we should walk away find our own
companies to to benefit find
our airlines find our sodas because this
is
bs and baseball was supposed to be
america's past time blaming it on
january 6th that is rich
this is all about the riots
no it's not yes it is nobody wants their
businesses destroyed juan
that's what this is let me tell you
something this no
it's not that's like saying the doctor
this isn't a good time
for a protest come on greg all right
coming up